I wanted to know him as you do I wanted
to be him I wanted to be the flash
you'll never be the flash exactly and
that realization everybody it's Charlie
this is gonna be my flash episode 10
video there was so much good Tom
Cavanagh reverse-flash
eel Bart dawn stuff that we have to
break down now obviously there was a big
metahuman plot someone trying to take
the mantle as one of the new lead rogues
with some fast and furious tech but I
really think the storyline they're
teeing up with Nora in the reverse-flash
is gonna be a little bit more rewarding
for long-term fans in big comic book
fans too so we'll do Easter eggs and top
10 WTF there's a new round of that flash
ring giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the episode on the
video so obviously careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the episode yet but
top-10 reverse-flash explains his
backstory to Nora so the story that he
tells is actually the Mark Waid version
of the origin story from the once and
future flash they actually did use the
title of that comic not the actual story
but just the title for the season 3
episode where Barry goes into the future
we meet emo Barry and we get this story
about Savitt are how he became a time
remnant then they come back there was
like late season 3 all anybody really
remembers from that episode is emo Barry
saddest man alive but the whole idea in
this episode is can bad people turn good
so he sort of teased that up when he
talks about his legacy and how
remorseful he is he doesn't want to be
known as the villain that everybody
thinks he is right now but I think they
did a good job of paying that off at the
end of the episode with that big WTF
cliffhanger that we'll talk about in a
second but if you never read that Mark
Waid origin story for eobard thawne is a
little bit different from the current
one right now during the rebirth era and
from the geoff johns era they sort of
retconned it just a little bit but it's
essentially the same story reverse-flash
gets his powers by reverse engineering
the accident that gave Barry his powers
using Barry's costume that he found in a
time capsule goes back into the past to
visit the flash Museum because he's so
in love with the idea of the flash he
just wants to see all things flash but
the big surprise that he finds is he
actually finds out that he's destined to
become the Flash's greatest villain and
it breaks him so when Tom Cavanagh is
reverse flash is talking about that is
right off of that
comic book page but this is 90s era
reverse-flash we're talking about and it
was Wally West at that time that he was
fighting Barry Allen was still stuck in
the Speed Force they hadn't brought him
back until rebirth so it was a long time
before Barry Allen ever actually came
back
number nine really awesome Easter egg
Nora and Barry talked about his green
and his blue suits obviously the flashes
weren't a couple of different blue suits
they're just winking a little bit at
future flash from the new 52 in the blue
costume as well as Blue Lantern Barry
Allen whose suit turns blue when he
wears the Blue Lantern ring which hasn't
happened in a while I don't think that
we're ever gonna see something like that
on the TV show but you can dream if you
really want Green Lantern stuff maybe
someday they'll get there but the thing
about the green flash suit is that
that's more of an Easter Egg for
Thaddeus Thawne inertia who's the evil
clone of Bart Allen he was sort of the
reverse-flash for Bart Allen Sarah
there's the thing in the comics where
they just used reverse flash as the term
for whoever the evil speedster is that's
facing that person so that's why hunter
zolomon was also called reverse flash
for a little while but the TV show kind
of changes that a little bit as far as
other versions of the reverse flash I
don't think that we're ever gonna see
inertia on the TV show unless they did
Bart and if Bart shows up on a TV show
it'll probably wind up being Titans
which is kind of in a different universe
so because she's kind of got that Bart
energy I don't think we're ever gonna
see Bart Allen on the flash TV show but
Never Say Never
like the whole idea with Nora during the
episode is they were trying to pay off
this arc where she eventually goes back
to agreed to help reverse flash and they
were using the weather which storyline
to do that so there was like a really
circuitous route for her to learn her
big lesson this week but number eight
huge WTF Cisco by far probably the most
bonkers person during the episode
suddenly thinks that curing all
metahumans is a great idea
though people will love this there's no
way that this could possibly go wrong
nobody evil will ever get their hands on
our cure and try to turn it against
humanity this is one of those storylines
where a character is gonna do something
and feel like it's justified even though
everybody in the audience knows that
it's gonna go off the rails and somebody
is gonna turn this cure into a weapon
and it's going to become a big deal in
the future timeline there's always like
one character every single week that
holds an idiot stick and does something
really stupid so this week is Cisco it's
just the beginning I expect this
metahuman cure storyline to last
most of the rest of the season seven
there was a big king Samson Easter egg
inside that garage that weather which in
silver ghosts went to if you've never
heard of Samson he's a time-traveling
descendant of the biblical version of
Samson so he has this super strength the
actual Samson and Delilah story from the
Bible you probably remember him from
that all-star Superman storyline but the
whole thing here is obviously whether
witch trying to decide whether or not
she's going to turn good and it's all
part of Nora's storyline so that she'll
come around on reverse-flash said oh
yeah bad people can turn good Silver
Ghost is a comic book character but the
way they explained her name is that it's
her callsign from the air force and
she's nothing like the comic book
version of the character who's like
another d-list villain that barely
appeared in any story so it's not that
big a deal you really only get upset
when they changed the really big a-list
characters really funny easter egg from
legends of tomorrow to number six
heatwaves dirty book unchained desire if
you guys don't watch legends of tomorrow
or you miss that in a previous season
heatwave had this running story line in
the background where he was writing a
dirty book so it was just really funny
to see that he was capable of writing
something like this and doing a good job
like the berry joke it's actually
surprisingly well-written but I do love
the other joke of Barry asking for food
and then bringing him big belly burger
also a running storyline with the Speed
Force times cymbals too because Sherlock
wells is on Nora's case trying to figure
out what she's trying to hide even
though she deleted all the evidence and
all her logs out of Gideon's database
he'll probably figure that out within
the next couple of episodes and things
will come to a head I don't think
they're gonna wait the entire rest of
the season before Barry finds out what
Nora's doing with reverse-flash in the
future it'll just be too much fun
watching him explode with rage
especially after number 5 Barry's big
speech about villains turning good with
Nora like if we don't believe in him who
will like he's basically telling her
because she literally mentioned zo Bart
thought maybe he could turn good someday
who knows so of course that won't come
back to bite him in the ass in the
future the whole thing about the Rogues
is that eventually they learned they can
take advantage of Barry's good nature
he's not gonna kill people so they try
to use that against him Superman as a
comic book character is the same way he
usually tells people don't mistake my
kindness for weakness I will take you
down but I'm trying to find a better way
to do this number four really big Batman
name drop
they mentioned waynetech again I think
this is all just building towards the
Batwoman TV show because even though
Bruce Wayne is sort of blowing off in
the wind elsewhere in the world Wayne
tech is still very much alive there are
people that still work there that are
also working with Batwoman right now
it's rumored that batwing is gonna be
one of the characters that will appear
on her TV show but they're only filming
the pilot right now they haven't
officially picked it up to series yet
they only picked it up for a pilot and
they'll be filming that pretty soon so
I'll be willing to bet that around the
time all the finales for most of the DC
TV shows are airing will hear more news
about that the way they explain the fast
and furious James Bond car is that it's
sort of an amalgam of the most advanced
tech that you could possibly get with
probably some advancements made based on
metahuman technology as well because
Amazo style it has all these abilities
that mimic some of the abilities that
the flash for instance has like it could
phase through things it can turn
invisible if it wants to you could make
a Batmobile reference but I don't know
what they're allowed to do in terms of
that when it gets to the Batwoman stuff
they might have to leave that off-limits
but they had the Batmobile on Titan's
and if they can do it on Titans maybe
they can do it on Batwoman as well but
number three Nora turns around on
weather which and she becomes as Barry
says her new version of captain Colt a
villain that became an ally eventually
so I wouldn't be surprised if weather
which comes back later this season and
helps her out defeat cicada or something
like that to was then going down into
Kaitlyn's dad's old lab oh he was
working on metahuman stuff down here
we'll use it to make our cure so I think
really what's going on with this is that
what will wind up happening is is they
synthesize an actual cure that works but
somebody else gets their hands on it and
if you remember that post-apocalyptic
timeline that Tsar II came from on
legends of tomorrow where metahumans
were outlawed they were all put in
prisons it'll be a situation like that
because of what happens with this cure
whether officially or unofficially just
seems like some big group is gonna try
and take control of it and use it to try
and control everyone regular humans and
metahumans alike but Sisko feels like it
would make everybody better what could
possibly go wrong
but that's will they be spending a lot
of their spare time in the next couple
of episodes number one WTF is you would
expect is reverse flashes countdown
clock is almost like Ned Stark on the
Block like this is all I could think
about when I
that clock very heavily implied to his
eventual execution because he's in iron
Heights prison he told Nora at their
last conversation there at the end I'm
running out of time and I want to make
things better so hopefully they'll be
more lenient on him or there'll be a
stay of execution I think that's what
he's hoping for things probably will not
go down the way you expect them it'll
probably go off the rails he'll either
wind up escaping or even Nora will do
something crazy that will allow him to
escape either knowingly or unknowingly
but if you look at his face in the way
that he reacts to Nora when she comes
back it's almost like you can see the
calculus going on in his brain like he
sounds very remorseful but the look on
his face says something very different
so I think that he's just trying to play
for time he's gonna do anything he can
to try and avoid that execution the
whole idea coming back to crisis on
Infinite Earths
in the passage about him in Nora's
future newspaper reverse-flash leads
army of shadow demons that's about as
evil as you can get inside the
arrowverse so all this talk of him being
remorseful and wanting to clean up his
legacy just seems like it's gonna come
back to bite him in the ass but let me
know in the comments if you spotted any
Azhar really big Easter eggs that I
didn't mention in the video what'll
happen is is I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post my flash trailer video
there's a new spider-man far from home
trailer with a whole bunch of different
footage that I'll be doing a video for
next that video will be up later today
so just look out for that click here to
rewatch the spider-man far from home
trailer a billion more times than all my
Easter eggs and click here to learn all
about Damian Wayne in Red Hood on Young
Justice season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]